>> As we know, role model isn't working as
much as it works in other places. Role models
in Amiris have some problems such as [pause]
social values such as religion. Such of the
communities like Islam, as you know Amiris
has many religions, Islam, Judaist, Christianity,
and other religions. It is a kind of problem
for successing role models. And also, countries
in Amiris have many problems to plan economy
plans such as role models. They have many
problems in social issues. They have tries
in their country using, many tries in one
country, that they can't use and they can't
plan economy care plans for their future.
I think that it is a problem but is not complexity
problem for the countries. With the remainder
of the time we can have role models for the
future. And it is far away from year end.
We have a lot of time to plan such pans in
our country and do it in the best way. Thank
you.